very first dangerous heat wave happening
this week so we begin this afternoon
with chief meteorologist ted florento
he's tracking new heat alerts that have
already been issued ted yeah heat alerts
for thursday and it is only monday that
tells you how serious this heat that
we're expecting this week is going to be
right now
that excessive heat watch begins on
thursday at 10 a.m last all the way
through sunday at 8 pm so those four
days are going to be our hottest days of
the year so far this is for areas below
4000 feet so las vegas included in this
the mountains not not much relief
outside right now because those winds
are staying fairly light but
temperatures are hot look at that
already at triple digits for north las
vegas in the high 90s for you close to
100 for las vegas areas like henderson
nellis already at 105. so here are
weather headlines our dangerous heat
wave our first one of the year coming
this week record temperatures are
possible we'll probably break them or
even tie them record highs and also
record warm lows and then gusty winds
late week could this mean that our
temperatures will be dropping later in
the week i'll let you know all that and
more in your most accurate forecast in
just a few minutes stay with